you're not gonna kiss me I'm hurt I'm
hurt first of all I just want to know
where your wife is because someone
spilled something on well yeah that's
okay somebody spilled something on you
right we'll champagne this is good
though because when we come home drunken
and the kids smell the alcohol on mommy
well say oh wait what she did was a tray
it wasn't that mommy's hammered again
umm emmy-winner
how does that feel oh yeah I won last
weekend I was like wow did you hear
something that I don't know the
post-show it was great you know I won
with Norman Lee aeran really let's be
honest Norman Lear's name is on the
ballot you're gonna win so I chose
wisely
you'll get your Emmy soon are you
excited about that they gave it to me
right away they what they do is they
mail the plaque later so you've got a
generic Emmy for about four weeks four
to six weeks a generic thing that's why
I have a staff of 12 working at my home
all right Jimmy I saw you talking to
James
what kind of shop do you guys talk when
you meet each other on the carpet do
tell
we don't really talk shop ever you know
you know actually everyone someone we do
complain because we are the only people
we can really complain to her of their
late-night talk show every once in a
while we'll get together and just start
complaining about things that we would
never discuss in public I never stopped
complaining it's one of the things that
makes me so charming so sweet did you
say I'm actually funnier than you do you
have the picture okay let's see by the
way Dobin to help he was really great
you just got right in the middle and
between me and the champagne
that's great guy Chan you're a witness
then it's not working okay now it is
working all right
that's the this is the aftermath you can
see I don't know if you can see yeah all
hell breaking loose their own it's a
dangerous place to be it really is well
you will you please go inside and take
your wife somewhere where she can dry
off and I ask who is your dress bye
I made it
right Marashi Hiroshi yes it's beautiful
thank you so much change to you minds by
marshals
[Music]